at some point today nearly everyone will
have stopped what they were doing and
absorbed the news
a notice was placed at Buckingham Palace
flags were lowered
our longest serving Monarch is gone
only on Tuesday did she look robust
appointing the 15th prime minister to
serve during her reign
in a statement his majesty the king said
the death of my beloved mother her
majesty the queen is a moment of the
greatest sadness for me and all members
of my family
we mourn profoundly the passing of a
cherished Sovereign and a much-loved
mother I know her loss will be deeply
felt throughout the country the Realms
and the Commonwealth and by countless
people around the world
during this period of mourning and
change my family and I will be comforted
and sustained by our knowledge of the
respect and deep affection in which the
queen was so widely held
we are all devastated by the news that
we have just heard from Balmoral
the death of her majesty the queen is a
huge shock to the nation and to the
world
Queen Elizabeth II was the rock on which
modern Britain was built
our country has grown and flourished
under her reign
Britain is the great country it is today
because of her
she ascended the throne just after the
second World War
she championed the development of the
Commonwealth from a small group of seven
countries to a family of 56 Nations
spanning every continent of the world
we are now a modern thriving Dynamic
Nation
through second thing
Queen Elizabeth II provided us with the
stability and the strength that we
needed
she was the very Spirit of Great Britain
and that spirit will endure
today we mourn the passing of a
remarkable sovereign
it is a deep private loss for the royal
family and our first thoughts are with
them at this time
the nation shares in their grief
throughout the day small unsettling
indicators emerged notes being passed
around the commons something's up I know
I speak on behalf of the entire house
when I said that we send our best wishes
to a Magister the queen and that she and
the royal family are in our thoughts and
prayers at this moment
doctors had expressed concern over the
Queen's condition Charles had canceled
an engagement their news that all senior
members of the family were heading to
Balmoral
and the grim look on faces as Prince
William drove his uncles Andrew and
Edward through the gates
finally a simple statement the queen
died peacefully at Balmoral this
afternoon
for more than 70 years Queen Elizabeth
has been the great constant in our
national life
she has inspired us on occasion Comfort
he does and always personified values we
hold dear
the United Kingdom now enters a period
of national mourning as we reflect on a
queen who kept her promise and dedicated
her life to duty
Jason Farrell Sky News Balmoral